>> Good morning, millennials.
>> We're plotting how to spend
our honeymoons together.
Maybe we all get a house.
>> Good morning, millennials.
>> They have millions of
followers on their social media.
They're known for throwing out
their opinions.
>> They're with us now.
Welcome, ladies.
When you heard --
>> The sound of my own voice,
makes me want to die.
You were waving, but not waving.
>> It's all love.
>> It's total love because what
you do is so genius, why do you
think your show has hit so hard
and resonated.
>> We attribute to a lot of the
success that we are sisters,
we're letting people in on our
sister vibe.
>> There's nothing we don't say
to each other, we don't have to
tiptoe around each other.
And it reminds them of their own
>> Have you ever been offended
by the other on air?
>> Of course.
We fight about Taylor Swift all
the time.
We agree on pretty much
everything.
>> I'm a normal fan, I love her
music, but the hyping up of
everything is annoying.
[ Laughter ]
>> I can't even hear it.
I'm just Taylor Swift poll
gist, and I make to apologies.
>> The new video, was it worth
all the hype?
>> Nothing can be worth that
much hype.
Unless she was putting out a
15-song album.
Technically it's a half a song.
Why did she have to dangle this
carrot stick for weeks in
it's just a song.
>> I feel the hype was
warranted.
>> Beautiful song, beautiful
video, beautiful collaboration.
>> You care about the cat, the
secret cat --
>> It's beautiful.
>> I'm a dog man, so I
understand the love she has.
It's a special bond.
>> What did you think about the
feature?
>> Love, love.
>> We respect the hell out of
panic! At the disco.
>> How do we feel -- how do
millennials feel about
Starbucks, per the taste, per
calorie, where are we?
>> Starbucks is trying too hard.
Just stop trying too much and
just make coffee.
>> This is what I'm wearing
today.
It's good for a photo.
>> I know you guys brought us
here to try it.
>> We have to --
>> I tried the other one and I
THR
threw up in my mouth.
>> Let's do it at the count of
three.
>> One, two, three.
That's delicious and I just
gained ten pounds.
>> That's so good.
>> I take back everything I
said.
>> I just had the best drink of
my life.
>> You need it because we're
back from stagecoach, the three
of us.
>> We like to do both.
>> What did you think of
stagecoach.
>> The best weekend ever.
>> This is country music
festival, a three nights of
music.
>> Real talent.
No one is singing with backup
vocals.
It's a man and his guitar -- or
>> What are the trends that we
like and what are the ones that
go bye-bye?
>> I saw a lot of crochet and
fringe.
And if I wore it, I think it's a
cool trend.
I think it's cool.
>> I saw a lot of chains, bikers
what I saw too much of was butt
cheek.
>> Lower?
>> The whole thing.
Just booty.
>> It's a kids festival, there
were butts everywhere.
>> I wasn't prepared for the
biker thing.
There's these women older than
me with handcuffs.
>> I'm into it.
>> What about Coachella.
Did you see Scott?
>> No.
>> He saw somebody.
>> You were saying.
>> Did we see each other?
>> He doesn't remember what
happened there.
>> Okay.
I was going to say, it's
possible, but it was a long
weekend.
And the drinks were flowing.
Coachella is a work environment,
everyone there is with brands
and getting the photo.
No one is there to actually
enjoy.
It was nice to go to stagecoach
and have a good time.
>> I'll tell you, I enjoyed.
>> Kim Kardashian having a baby
shower, what do we think?
>> I'm newly obsessed with CBD
and I sleep like a log now.
>> What is CBD?
>> It's the marijuana plant,
there's two things in it, thc
and CBD, you can take just that,
it's legal and it helps you
it has a lot of the positive
effects of marijuana.
>> Google it because it's worth
CBD.
>> I'm hitting it.
>> "The morning toast" is live
on YouTube.
Thank you so much.
>> Nice to see you guys.